the next aggressive opening we're going
to be looking at is our only opening
from Black's perspective and it is the
Latvian Gambit I've been playing it more
and more just because it's so much fun
to see your opponent's face when you
play it they really think you have no
clue what you're doing and it's really
fun to play so Pawn to E4 upon E5 pretty
common Knight to F3 which you're gonna
see all the time so you're gonna have
many many opportunities to actually play
the Latvian gamut and then you're gonna
play Pawn 2 F5 pretty crazy opening
there's a lot of different ways that
white can respond to this especially if
they've never seen it they may try
something super crazy uh so that's why
there's another video specifically about
that there's a lot of different ways to
bring the bishop here to C5 and actually
give up material even The Rook or the
queen if you want to and just go ahead
and attack this score here on F2 so a
lot of different ways you can do this
but no matter how you slice it the
laving gamut is definitely one of the
best aggressive openings